voici long de ce chemin
comme des grands frères les grands pas
lorànt deutsch j'ai 26 ans est comédien
correct correct on vous a découvert dans
le ciel les oiseaux et ta mère djamel
bensalah en 1999
on vous a revu dans peut-être dans
l'envol dans là bas mon pays
mais c'est à partir de jet set de fabien
oteniente que les directeurs de casting
ont commencé à vous téléphoner pour des
films plus important après il ya eu un
aller simple film pour lequel vous
auriez dû être nommé aux césar c'est je
l'espérais beaucoup parce que j'ai du
respect pour la profession aimons cette
académie un petit peu et je vous aurais
voulu un clin d'oeil de mes pairs de
m'encourager me disant mais c'est bien
tu es sur la bonne voie continue et ça
n'a pas été le cas j'en veux à personne
sauf à moi j'ai pas travailler assez
bien ou les autres étaient meilleurs
vous avez un vrai effort sur ce film en
quoi je m'étais battue parce que fallait
que j'évite j'avais un accent
marseillais dans l'histoire et moi je
suis très très loin de marseille édouard
l'accent marseillais pour un hôpital si
vieux maintenant laissez moi partir du
moment où tu parles
l accent marseillais bon il faut éviter
de rajouter toujours détruire ce que
font les parisiens quoi ouais mais bon
voilà 0
bush
nation déjà franchement bon ensuite il
ya eu le raid heureux djamel bensalah
est aujourd'hui 3 0 de re fabien
oteniente fidèles
une saison pleine
chacun à sa place fait quoi au fond
c'est ça passe ou ça casse
on y va
tout se joue pas
cb
voilà ses motivations c'est la musique
des films 3 0 de fabien oteniente de
stomy bugsy voilà avec gérard lanvin
samuel le bihan gérard darmon achille à
dire si la champions's league
isabelle nanty et vous donc lorànt
deutsch secrètement en invité ce soir
alors à quelques semaines de la coupe du
monde c'est une très bonne idée
effectivement d'en faire un film sur le
foot business va nous préparer au
plaisir de re voir l'équipe de france
gagner la coupe du monde avec des mains
allez messieurs la pression j'arrête un
penalty là non vient alors le film c'est
l'histoire de tibor kovacs qui est un
jeune hongrois d'une vingtaine d'années
en prison pour des délits mineurs
c'est vous donc les bras et là vous
faites la connaissance de manu alias
samuel le bihan décide de faire de vous
une star du foot il devient votre agent
et à partir de là on va suivre les
aventures des deux compères dans
l'univers impitoyable du ballon rond
d'abord faut trouver un manager et c'est
gérard lanvin qui va s'y coller ouais il
est réfugié à rio ont fait de chercher
des niches et là bas à copacabana lui
c'est dans l'histoire c'est samuel le
bihan qu'à la chance d'aller au brésil
voilà j'ai fait que le père étant de la
chapelle j'ai fait tous les stades de
foot je suis gâté un déjà sur au jet set
alors que les autres banques dans
laquelle raide quand même tu avais rien
à faire au bénéfice ben non c'est mort
on a mangé du riz pendant deux mois
moi je me suis embrouillé avec une tribu
d'indiens congé draguer une fille cd
une vertu à coup de sagaie non non
c'était honteux des problèmes moi voilà
puis ensuite il faut éviter d'être
dévorés par les requins du foot business
comme gérard darmon alias oscar marc
vélo voilà j'ai remarqué ça fait om 1 1
il ya plein de films avec un sens caché
à chaque fois il ya plusieurs couches un
savoureux